[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu connais le flublok Casanova reprends-le
oh mon dieu je suis tellement désolé je vais bien je vais
bien
du
tonnerre ne le vois-tu pas,
attrape ton copain Thunder et dis ces
mots magiques va
te faire [ __ ] Thunder tu peux me sucer la [ __ ]
tu ne peux pas m'avoir le tonnerre parce que tu es juste
des pets de Dieu
[Musique]
J'ai emmené un avocat dîner  tu ne penses pas
qu'elle va s'attendre à quelque chose de
rendez-vous tu veux comme l'anal pas comme le
cancer Kulick truc en or sur le doigt
oh [ __ ] papa ça fait quatre ans Johnny
toi et moi sommes ensemble depuis 27
ans
où est ma bague hein ce
[ __ ] de connard marmonnant  qu'est-ce que tout cela souris plus il a le
doigt tu viens
[Musique]
Je dis seulement ça parce que je t'aime
si tu veux que Ted déménage pour que nous
puissions continuer nos vies Je ne suis pas si
pressé de le vérifier  out j'ai rencontré
une fille c'est une caissière pas du
tout c'est génial  w
la ligne
bien qu'est-ce qu'un nom de poubelle blanche oui
Manny non
Marilyn non Britney Oh Tiffany non
Janice
oh ne baise pas avec moi là-dessus je sais
cette merde tu me vois baiser avec tu
as le glacial rouillé je vais en
débiter  des noms quand je l'ai frappé et
que je l'ai fait vibrer oh je ne vous ai pas dit que vous m'aviez eu ouais d'
accord Brandi avait le chant
Brianna ambre Sabrina mélodie Dakota
Sierra bébé cristal Samantha automne Ruby
Taylor Tyra Tammy Lauren bombardant
Chantal Courtney brumeuse Jenny Kristin
Mindy pas bien elle  ce sera Trina Reba
Cassandra Nikki Kelsey Shonda Jolene
earlene Claudine Savannah Casey dolly
tendre collie Chloe Devon Emma Lusaka
Becky
non attends était-ce l'un de ces noms
avec une Lynn après ça oui d'accord Brandi laisse
Heather et Tammy gagner
[Musique]
toi